une arrestation dénoncé par les
syndicats notamment le syndicat national
des journalistes mais aussi force
ouvrière écouter françoise chazot
secrétaire général fo fédération presse
et audiovisuel
elle estime que cette arrestation est
inquiétante
retenir des journalistes durant cette
heure c'est éprouvant pour eux
évidemment mais c'est quand même assez
menaçants c'est et c'est inquiétant je
redis c'est assez inquiétant mais dans
une zone européenne qui est qui n'est
pas en guerre donc le principe on doit
aller normalement on doit aller où on
veut c'est pas une zone où il n'y avait
pas de danger
d'explosifs qui avait pas un danger pour
la santé il y avait juste ce danger
d'avoir de l'information pour pour la
pologne c'est ça qui est inquiétant moi
je dis que c'est pas normal et je pense
que la presse est unanime là dessus et
nous rejoint temps espère que les
journalistes désertaient pourront
librement partout partout où ils doivent
tête et partout ils doivent faire leur
métier pourront exercer librement enfin
la liberté d'informer la liberté
d'expression la liberté de rendre compte
même si ça plaît pas toujours c'est
important